we're talking about offseason story
lines and one that has percolated very
quickly this back and forth between the
eagles and quarterback nick foles the
eagles have already exercised the 20
million option for 2019 folz has already
exercised his prerogative to buy out of
it for 2 million so now the question
becomes do the eagles apply the
franchise tag at roughly 25 million and
the thinking is chris they would do it
in order to trade folds not to pay him
25 million dollars to be the backup and
let me start there yeah because there's
a little bit of a legal argument i want
to get to right if the goal is to trade
him yeah let's do this first do you
think it makes sense to pay nick foles
25 million to be the backup quarterback
behind carson wentz for 2019. no i do
not think that makes sense uh from from
the point of yes i mean having two guys
that are looked at and valued as nfl
starters in the same locker room i think
that's an issue as one and no it would
be very hard for me to have a guy on the
bench for the just in case this happens
uh theory or factor and paying him 25
million dollars
and when you consider that carson wentz
in the final year of his rookie contract
i think his salary i'm pulling it up now
now of course he got a big signing bonus
and yeah part of that money applies to
this year but good luck telling that
when he sees his base salary for this
year is 720 000
now again he got a 17 million signing
bonus and 4.4 million of it counts
against this season but still when it's
time to get checks it's going to be 727
720 000 divided by 17. for falls it's
going to be 25 million divided by 17.
that's going to make an awkward
situation even more awkward i think the
one thing you and i agreed on at the end
of the season for the eagles whatever
they do between winston falls you can't
try to keep both of them no you have to
you have to pick one and let the other
one go yeah that's 100 and i think we've
already seen little inklings of how that
can be an issue right i mean the story
last week about you know some of the
unnamed sources of eagles players saying
carson wentz was you know a little
spoiled or entitled whatever it may be
you know that chatter and i know some of
the eagles players have tried to silence
it but that is only going to continue uh
especially if nick foles is still in the
locker room there is going to be guys
whether they like both guys or not that
are going to side with one quarterback
over the other and that can be an issue
it can be divisive to your team and the
eagles are still a talented team who can
win a lot of football games and i don't
think they want that
yeah i mean if wentz is the week one
starter as he would be and he struggles
at all and we don't know what their
schedule is going to be maybe their
toughest three games of the year or
right out of the gates yes right and
he's not playing well and you got guys
in the locker room saying why are we
paying this guy 25 million he's he's
here he's ready to go we know what he
can do yes it's so so we've ruled out
that it makes sense for the eagles to
pay nick foles 25 million to be the
backup so the only logical reason why
they would use the franchise tag on nick
foles is so they could hold his rights
long enough to trade him that's where it
becomes a problem for the eagles under
the collective bargaining agreement
article 4 section 8 subsection b says a
club extending a franchise tender must
for as long as the tender is extended
have a good faith intention to employ
the player receiving the tender at the
tender compensation level during the
upcoming upcoming season which means in
english you can't tag him just to trade
him if you tag him you must intend to
keep him and pay him for the full season
you must have an intention to do it you
can still trade him later right but you
can't go into it saying we're doing this
for one reason and one reason only to
preserve dibs on him so we can trade him
to someone else and and this is where i
get back to what i've been saying about
nick foles chris he needs to drop the
nice guy facade and say hey you guys are
going to screw around with me i'm going
to screw around with you if you're going
to franchise tag me i'm filing a
grievance challenging your ability to do
it because you're only doing it so you
can trade me to jacksonville or denver
or anywhere but the giants are
washington right okay so now let me put
on my lawyer hat because i know i'm not
in your class there but the first thing
i got was well how does the nfl prove
that that the eagles aren't trying to
sign him to the team how how do we know
what if the eagles make a bullcrap offer
for like less than starting quarterback
money to say hey we'd like you to be
here to be our backup so what does the
nfl do there even though the eagles are
offering something and trying to make it
look like you know hey we want this guy
and we're trying to work it out
they can make it look like that right
mike and still not really be doing that
and then not breaking the the cba
agreement here am i correct with that or
am i wrong well well here's how it would
work yeah
i mean they can say anything they want
but i think what what foals should do is
force them right you make the argument
that you don't have a good faith
intention to employ me this year and pay
me 25 million dollars to be the backup
to carson wentz that this is all about
setting up a trade you make that
argument then the eagles have to say
what they're doing and based upon the
argument they make then you poke holes
in it and there was a report from adam
shafter over the weekend that other
teams believe that this is what they're
doing they're going to tag him and trade
him sure and here's the line the eagles
are expected to use the franchise tag on
nick foles in an effort to then try to
trade him according to sources on other
nfl teams who have been in touch with
philadelphia right so you know what that
tells me yeah that tells me that if your
nick falls and he will say no no no no
we want to pay you 25 million dollars to
sit on the bench or hold a clipboard
then you say hey nfl we want emails we
want text messages we want to take
discovery on the question of the
communications the eagles have had with
other teams we want howie roseman's uh
you know the list of all the calls he's
made on his cell phone what what teams
he's called hey howie why did you call
jacksonville on january the 3rd that
that's how you would attack what
possibly is a bs explanation yeah they
can say whatever they want right but
then the lawyer representing falls
swoops in and says here's why this is a
bunch of crap here's why this is all
cover yeah for what they're trying to do
yeah which is trade nick falls and if
that's what they're trying to do yeah
they shouldn't use the franchise tag
right they are trying to do that i mean
certainly it seems like that that's the
logical thing that's what i would be
doing if i'm the philadelphia eagles i i
guess the other thing i would say
there's a but okay so but it violates
the cba so it's logical but it violates
the cbs okay but no but so what if i'm
just throwing what ifs out there what if
they also say but no we offered nick we
want nick falls here we offered him four
years 40 million like him so wait a
minute chris how are you offering him
four years 40 million but he's making 25
million for one man they can say we're
offering him that we'd like him to come
back and be our backup for four years 40
million he didn't want to accept that
offer so therefore he's franchised and
now we're going to find a trade deal
that's all i'm saying i'm just trying to
throw you know some some holes in your
hairy there but you have to intend to
employ him as your backup quarterback at
25 million dollars okay you and i can
agree that they don't intend surely they
don't intend to pay this guy 25 million
dollars to be the backup to carson wentz
no surely they don't i don't think they
intend either but i think that takes
over but but that's very hard for the
nfl to be able to prove that i mean the
eagles are going to say no we're okay
with that our starting quarterback as
you said made 700 is making 700 000 so
at the end of the day 25 million and 700
000
is like the going rate for starting
quarterback in football and the eagles
will be able to say that so we're okay
with that i mean okay fine then then you
know what you're stuck with nick foles
for a year at 25 million dollars i mean
my point is nick foles doesn't want to
be there because he wants to go
somewhere else so i'm just saying i'm
i'm actually a pretty good lawyer i
think i'm pretty good no you're not no
because here's the thing the eagles are
going to light this fuse and they have
no idea where the fuse is going to go
and they have no idea how big the bomb
is it's eventually going to go off my
point is they are playing chess with
nick foles who is just kind of sitting
back and being passive about it and i i
want to see a little bit more out of
falls i mean if this guy is going to
take over a new franchise if he's going
to be the guy that jacksonville needs
don't you want to see a little fire from
him now don't you want to see him a
little bit pissed off about what the
eagles are doing is there a correlation
in your mind between how nick foles
handles his business off the field and
how he handles his business on no i mean
i'll use the quarterback you drag on all
the time i mean kirk cousin seems like
he's the best damn business guy in all
of football but you you you'll tell me
all the time that you want his butt out
of town so uh you know there's no
correlation there i think some teams
might like the fact that a nick foles
would be quiet and just sit back it's
gonna it's gonna show them look this guy
loves football he's not worried about
penny pinching for every dollar he
doesn't make a big deal when things
don't go his way he'll never be a
distraction that's the kind of leader
that we want as our quarterback i think
that and more and more lines in the nfl
will be looked at as a positive than
than maybe what you're saying
did you say penny pinching penny pencil
i think you said i think you said it's
you know it's penny pinching yes but you
said penny pence i think i might have
yes i mean is it is this the first time
you've heard me butcher the english
language
i just wanted to make sure that my ears
all of a sudden weren't failing no no
all right kenny pinching sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports